hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video gewiss ja freunde youtube ist
wirklich so ein krasses ging man kann
damit echt eine menge spass machen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich könnte
mir jetzt mal was auch durch durch ihr
wisst ja viele leute kaufen sich autos
der leute investieren kameras in drohen
kann ich nachvollziehen deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich könnte mir ein
schloss meine damen und herren
jetzt kommt antwortet
angeliefert
normalerweise gehört das ding komplett
wir als ich das komplett war geteilt
aber ich hab's der familienkonzern am
stuhl 3 18 71 genau deswegen meine damen
und herren ich jetzt einfach mal sagen
gehen wir mal an dieser habe ich ja
eigentlich schon ist errechnet hat nicht
los
2000 jahre später deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich zeige ob das jetzt einfach
mal ihr seht schon ich glaube die treppe
hoch das sind die treppen verdient zum
schloss eingang wo herzlich willkommen
jetzt hier in meinem schlossen wir haben
hier vorne derzeit hält mein ganzes
nötig kamera ist ordner erinnerte
schmidt auf der rechten seite die kritik
riss es das hier ist der eingangsbereich
ist mein pony oder viele wettkämpfe
bestritten habe der gute alte enger hier
natürlich auch ballhaus anlagen
vorhanden und in vorne ist erstmal ein
relativ großer saal noch an kalorien
vorhanden sind nämlich die treppen hoch
wir haben wirklich alles komplett mit
tollen heutige länder ausgestattet auch
beachtet das wirklich hier als deko über
die feinsten bilder gewählt werden
video von jungfrau maria wenn man hier
einmal das schloss zeigen und ihre
kosten
genau nach dem jetzt einmal den willen
müssen was darüber erzielt haben gebe es
hier natürlich weiter nach oben hier
sehen nämlich ein paar leute hey gute
das ist was was seine aufgabe
butler genau das ist seine aufgabe was
machst du das so dessen tragen nicht
tragen
so habe ich alex halt's maul du reitest
die köpfe in der tat es ich bin hier
wirklich ein herzloser schlossbesitzer
ich kann mir die ganzen mitarbeiter mit
den fingerspitzen
das ist eine aufgabe hier dich aus dem
konzept nicht aus dem konzept bringen
danke felix wir sehen uns mit eintritt
dankeschön wir sehen uns auf jeden fall
beim essen die da wir vorne haben wir
uns den theatersaal regel in den grünen
salon tschuldigung der vermieteten
studio 83 ein 17-jähriger brett der
traktor pulling was
es gehört das hier ist mein balkon zu
einseitig hab noch 7 auf der anderen
seite hat mit schön hier seid ihr
neidisch hammer es fängt an zu trinken
geben wie die wagen schon das ist mein
stil dem bericht derzeit der meisten
aufhalte dass sie jetzt auf jeden fall
so das zimmermädchen habe
angela mehr anderen wir haben riesige
kleiderschrank schreibtisch ledig ist
alles wirklich gerade habe ich habe ich
wirklich mal gedacht volle wenn ich euch
das ganze jetzt wirklich mal zeige dann
soll es auch real sein und meine knie
betriebsleiter johann haben
hier obwohl ich mache schon mehrmals
benutzt wir haben hier eine frau die
sich selbst befriedigt also den
kompletten sind jetzt unter nicht
verstanden auf jeden fall ihres
fahrrades zu sein wäre mir auch schöne
fenster klopfen auf holz im garten
gucken oder kurz den karten gehen nicht
ob wir gehen jetzt einfach mal in den
garten
also das ist quasi der komplette garten
wir haben verschiedene sachen gerne nach
vorne beispielsweise im fußball platz
haben basketballplätze verspeisen kann
was trinken kann sind tnt zum mittag in
wodka am abend ich kann man hier alles
machen
es regnet halt ein bisschen fakt halt
auch sera das war es jetzt auch wirklich
meine damen und herren hier von der
schloss tui setzt auch hier wieder ein
gebilde das ist mein job ist wirklich
sehr schön ich wurde ganz knapp und spaß
ist das war schon wieder meine damen und
herren es war wirklich nur so eine
gewisse verarscht ich hab das schon mal
gemacht als ich mir sich zum porsche
geliehen hatte einfach mal so zu tun als
wäre es mein auto und das gleiche ist
hier mit dem schloss ich bin nämlich ihr
wegen seiner studien 70 sache relativ
cool
wir haben halt leider kein netz so dass
es jetzt halt nicht so cool aber wasser
ganz leichtes ist dass ihr halt
irgendwie in diesem schloss hier wohne
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht komm ich
verrate euch mal und gesagt ein schloss
gekauft hatte sagt mal ganz ehrlich noch
keiner von euch jetzt irgendwie
vorgestellt oder keiner von euch hat es
geglaubt verscheiden hlinka video
vielleicht trotzdem gefallen hat von der
machart würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen schreibt wendy kommentare ob
ihr euch er ein schloss kaufen würde
oder ein sportwagen oder yacht wenn ihr
das geld hätte ich würd mir pizza kaufen
glaubt übrigens david ist kameramann
also ich hab eigentlich ein anliegen
würde mich riesig freuen wenn man auf
die seite von klicks gehen würde glaubt
lukas raps vielleicht irgendwo ein mini
bock habt bisschen mucke
danke fürs duschen